c'est déjà bien c'est déjà un plus mais
ce n'est pas suffisant il faut vraiment
que le ministre de l'intérieur que le
mélézin l'outre-mer comprennent bien que
nous sommes dans une situation de
délinquance et notamment en terme d'
homicide
le très hâtif d'homicide qui est au
dessus au dessus je dis bien au dessus
puisque nous somme d'à peu près sans
doute heures 2e ou 3e territoire
français le plus criminogène
nous sommes au dessus de la moyenne
nationale d'accord nous ne sommes pas
dans le même câble de derek haas que la
moyenne nationale
ce n'est pas vrai nous sommes à l'heure
d'hiver le 13 février
nous avons déjà eu trois homicides et
nous sommes à peu près à six tentatives
d'homicide
c'est une année qui commence bien mal le
carnaval arrive il ya des festivités qui
seront organisées il ya nécessité de ne
pas faire des petits pansements sur les
grosses blessures que nous avons ici en
termes de sécurité
mais vraiment vraiment d'abonder en
effectifs suffisants les différents
direction de police et je pense
notamment à l'eau face au srpj et la
ddsp d'enfer